whatever happened to jabba the hutt's
son where did the crimson dawn go who
was snoke anyway keep watching for more
star wars storylines that were lost a
long time ago in a galaxy far far away
star wars the clone wars is often
commended by fans for filling in the
many blanks that have been left behind
by the prequel trilogy but one plot
point that neither the show nor the
films ever elaborated on was the notion
that anakin had no father theoretically
he was conceived via the force similar
to mary's virgin birth of jesus christ
and the christian religion but it's
never mentioned again after shmi
skywalker first tells quagon jinn how
this happened in the disney canon is
still a mystery in legends the darth
plagueis novel explained that
palpatine's master had discovered how to
influence the force to such a degree
that he could use it to create life
itself he taught palpatine how to use
this power and when they experimented
with it they accidentally created anakin
this revelation meant that the sith had
literally created the person that would
eventually destroy them and the idea had
a sort of poetic justice to it that many
fans found quite appealing back when the
phantom menace was released however
details about shmi's immaculate
conception had been received with
indifference by many which likely led
the main star wars universe to downplay
it in subsequent installments
in 2008 lucasfilm released an animated
movie called star wars the clone wars
this was basically a theatrical pilot
for the upcoming television series of
the same name and its plot revolved
around jabba the hutt's son rota
secretly kidnapped by count dooku's
agents the party that managed to return
rhoda to his father would be granted
access to key hyperspace lanes
controlled by jabba greatly aiding their
war efforts anakin skywalker and his new
apprentice ahsoka tano eventually rescue
roda and secure jabba's help and then
rota the hut is never seen again
to this day fans have no idea what
became of the little hutlet certainly by
the time jabba is killed by princess
leia and her crew rota is nowhere to be
seen it's quite possible that rota had
simply moved out of jabba's tatooine
palace by this point and that he's still
happily operating a crime cartel in some
other distant corner of the universe but
it's a surprising fact that a character
as significant as jabba has a son whose
fate remains unknown especially since a
continuation of his story could be
pretty interesting
when count dooku's droid army captures
obi-wan kenobi in attack of the clones
he tells obi-wan that a sith lord is
controlling the republic senate
yet despite the fact that this admission
should have been a major red flag for
the jedi order the jedi do nothing with
this knowledge as far as fans know the
jedi never investigate the claim or look
into it in any meaningful way this plot
point could have been a major revelation
one with serious ramifications spawning
numerous storylines instead the claim is
never followed up on only mentioned a
few times in subsequent star wars
iterations and dismissed half-heartedly
each time though it makes sense that the
jedi wouldn't take the villain at his
word it is strange that they've never
investigated it either on-screen or in
the pages of a comic or novel
over the course of episodes 18 and 19 of
season 2 the clone wars introduced its
own version of godzilla they named the
creature the zillow beast as an obvious
homage to the japanese creation and soon
had the monster rampaging through the
streets of coruscant in the first
episode the zillow beast the creature is
awakened from its long slumber on the
planet of malistaire
though the planet's natives want to
destroy and kill the creature palpatine
and the jedi secretly save the
creature's life and bring it to
coruscant to study and preserve it the
creature briefly escapes during the
zillow beast strikes back however before
the republic finally manages to kill it
the episode ends with palpatine taking
its body for further study and ordering
his head scientists to attempt to clone
it it is never mentioned again to this
day fans don't know what if anything
came about as a part of this research of
course the end universe explanation
would be that palpatine scientists fail
since zillow clones have never been seen
and no lightsaber-resistant armor has
ever materialized within the empire but
it's not certain why the show's creators
chose to end the episode on something of
a cliffhanger only to never address it
again
when lucasfilm released solo a star wars
story in theaters in 2018 nobody could
have anticipated one of its most
surprising cameos maul
played in person once again by ray park
with rebels and clone wars act as sam
witt were returning to voice him darth
maul is revealed in the latter half of
the film as the head of the dreaded
crimson dawn cartel this is another
storyline that would never be seen again
the next time fans see maul in the
timeline is throughout the second and
third seasons of rebels by which point
maul has been stranded alone on malachor
for years and no longer leads anybody
let alone a vast criminal network
although it's still unknown exactly how
maul went from intergalactic crime boss
to lone survivor one possible answer
might be found in an old interview with
alden ehrenreich according to ehrenreich
he had signed on for three films
potentially indicating that lucasfilm
had been planning on making a solo
trilogy of sorts if this was the case
the next two movies might have featured
maul more prominently if nothing else
though there's at least a chance fans
might get to learn how he fell from
grace in marvel's crimson reign
miniseries the force awakens introduced
a new alien to the franchise maz kanata
a friend of han solo and apparently
chewie's ex maz is the pirate queen of
takadana and before her castle is
destroyed by the first order it acts as
a hub for smugglers from across the
galaxy but force sensitive herself ma
spent her millennia long lifetime
collecting artifacts of all kinds within
the storehouses of her castle one
surprising item in her collection is the
lightsaber that anakin skywalker built
during the clone wars which later passed
down to luke before the force awakens
the blade had last been seen falling
into the abyss during luke's duel with
vader on cloud city that lightsaber was
luke's
and his father's before him and now
it calls to you
many understandably believed the
lightsaber to be lost forever and yet
maz kanata somehow found it but how if
maz have been alive for a millennia
where was she during the other films did
she know any other jedi and could she
even appear in the ongoing high republic
project though the fate of the weapon
was teased in the pages of the comics
nothing more was revealed about it other
than it was found fans can only hope
that they'll one day get the answers to
these questions
one of the major turning points in the
force awakens is the destruction of the
new republic capital at the hands of the
first order's newer superweapon
starkiller base subsequently many fans
speculated about what might happen to
the new republic in the next film
founded after the events of return of
the jedi the new republic had been a
major facet of the legend story set in
that time period and so speculation ran
amuck as to what it might look like in
the canon universe sadly the new
republic never made a proper appearance
in the sequel trilogy in both the last
jedi and the rise of skywalker the new
republic is simply gone apparently
audiences were meant to believe the
destruction of its capital immediately
and totally destroyed the entire
republic for the second time in the
skywalker saga this was a disappointing
choice for those who wish to see the
promises of the original trilogy
fulfilled and even though we've seen
glimpses of the new republic in the
mandalorian and star wars squadrons the
movie's treatment of this new government
leaves a lot to be desired
the force awakens introduced the galaxy
to a brand new super villain the
mysterious supreme leader snoke in the
wake of the movie's release fans and
media outlets around the world
speculated wildly about snoke's real
identity putting forth all kinds of wild
theories about who he might be then the
last jedi arrived in theaters in 2017
and not only did it provide fans with no
new information about the supreme leader
but it killed off the villain at the end
of the second act snoke's identity and
backstory apparently didn't matter to
the wider story a sentiment that was
only reinforced in the rise of skywalker
in which snoke is revealed to be a
creation of darth sidious though his
identity has seemingly been answered
what little clues that fans were given
about his history and backstory were
tantalizing hinting that he and luke
skywalker had already met at least once
in the past snoke may have been little
more than a tool of palpatine but his
backstory did hold potential for future
exploration arguably it still does
during the events of the rise of
skywalker as the movie's heroes find
themselves trapped in quicksand finn
yells this to rey hey
ray i never told you
the entire group would miraculously
emerge unscathed from the encounter yet
for some reason finn never felt the need
to continue his train of thought many
assumed he wanted to say i love you but
various comments from the cast have cast
doubt on this theory john boyega who
played finn has since confirmed that
this isn't what he was supposed to say
but he hasn't provided an alternate
answer either instead fans will likely
have to continue relying on rumored
reports of an overheard conversation at
the film's premiere in which j.j abrams
reportedly said that finn was about to
tell rey he was force sensitive finn is
able to identify the command ship
correctly by feeling at the battle of
exicle in theory he has the potential to
become a jedi an idea that fits well
with another open-ended plot point that
appears later in the film when the team
travels to the ruins of the second death
star they meet a battalion of first
order stormtroopers who have all chosen
to rebel of their own accord just like
finn though it's not stated explicitly
it is implied that each of the former
stormtroopers who rebelled did so
because they were force sensitive as
well
alas this storyline was dropped almost
immediately and it seems unlikely that
it will ever return
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]